the jurogan experience i
yeah no it was really weird because i
was in the area that i lived
um that's where tony lived they burnt
yeah they burned cop cars like in
very near my house he used to love that
area it was so beautiful
it was so nice and now it's all full of
tents it was really it was really rough
do you know that they're spending
[ __ ] oh you ready for this jamie
how about this i'm gonna send you this
jamie because this is [ __ ] crazy
um but as we're talking [ __ ] on los
angeles they're still at homeless people
well
there's a there's no it's nothing in
comparison
it's a smaller town what's this one
instagram account yeah
oh it's just people love los angeles
street people of los angeles good gutter
people of los angeles is better
that's my favorite oh my god you guys
this is sad this is the video i was
looking at that when you're talking
about this like
activist lady is trying to i guess help
but there's also a guy with a machete
jamie when you watched this the first
time what part did you come
he comes all the time he just comes
multiple times
not as like a top cigarette but not like
tom i'm going to send you something
jamie
um this is uh you remember how kolian
noir was on and he was talking about how
the reason why the homeless situation
never gets fixed is because so many
people
um are working on the homeless situation
and they spend hundreds of millions of
dollars
l.a spent i thought it was there was no
money that's not the case
hundreds of millions of dollars gets
spent on the homeless and thank you for
your contribution to that but you know
where it goes to but you know where it
goes to it goes through salaries of
people working on the homes
so this uh someone posted all the
salaries of all these people
look at they're all like six figures and
more look at it 254
263 000 198 000
264 000 like they make a shitload of
money
you would think it is like it is a job
you would want to pay people a lot
because you want them
you want like great mind this is a
result this is a puzzle like this is a
puzzle someone needs to solve
but you want results when you get no
results you shouldn't get that much
exactly and there's too many people
there should be like
a committee of five people no experts
you you need a lot of people to deal
with the homeless situation in la it's a
hundred thousand homeless people
you have you have boulder colorado in
l.a
in homeless like take the entire
population to boulder
and make it homeless and then put it in
l.a boulder so the opposite of that boat
is just these gorgeous
fit hikers hikers yeah they're like
they're hot but they're wearing those
like toe shoes and like tivos so you
wouldn't bang them but you're like
i understand they're taking like a yoga
mat to the top they got a yoga mat
they're wearing joe rogan this is a
story i heard in
on the la news that uh they had these
they bought these things for the
homeless shelter situation
and they were just hanging out near at
dodger stadium unused until someone
found them with like a drone one day you
know what that's not going to fix
anything
either i want one of those they spend a
bunch of money on right but here
so then you're going to get homeless
people and they're going to live in
these things
they're going to make it so however the
way they want to this guy is talking
about
they're going to live however the way
they want to on in those things
up there just doing drugs and lighting
things on fire and
it's like nice living in l.a like it's
like the weather is beautiful
well that's why they like to go down the
beach it's very you know it's very
maintained but i think ocean air comes
off i think what they're doing i know
they have
beachfront uh property they do they're
putting decks on i'm like you guys this
is crazy you guys are living a better
life
venice is bananas but venice is um
i think they did something where they're
you can't loiter or litter or something
so now
the homeless people are like cleaning
it's like cleaner
what the [ __ ] or they can arrest
themselves you can't camp how about that
get the [ __ ] out of here yeah and you
know you kind of figure
i noticed the other day there's people
that are not
quite homeless yet that's how you know
it's like these are drug addicts like
it's like people that are not you see
them like
leaning into that life where you're like
if they weren't allowed to camp they
would probably
it's just that they're shitty the whole
thing is dumb you can't allow but you
just camp on streets in the middle of
nowhere you just can't
you just can't in the middle of your
streets yeah put tents up
you just can't allow that you know they
passed a ban on it here and
today supposed to be the day that the
second phase goes
i was gonna say because i've been i
can't allow my king to tell me there's
no homeless people no there's homeless
people there's just not a lot
yes there are no there's two thousand
two to three thousand it's a small place
i see them
everywhere well there's a lot i mean in
terms of like i'm telling you i saw this
obese homeless woman
bottomless running across i mean the
amount of vaginas i see in this goddamn
business
but she was running across wearing a
mask i was like i was promised no mass
and no homeless people and i'm getting
a mixture of both catch new episodes of
the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience